BEN: Hey, this is Ben again, and
we are at the Google I/O
After Hours Party.
We've got amazing things
to see here.
Let me find my collaborator
here.
Hey!
FITZ: Hey, Ben!
BEN: How was that?
FITZ: That was great!
This is a VirtuSphere.
It's a virtual reality
in a sphere, and
they've got two of them.
And people are going to be going
head-to-head combat here
at the After Hours
Party for Google.
BEN: Fantastic.
There's a bunch of other crazy
robotic things we're going to
show you tonight.
FITZ: What else do we have?
BEN: Brainwave games that read
your brain and lets you do
amazing things.
FITZ: We've got a 38-foot
mechanical snake.
BEN: And we've got a bunch of
autonomous flying helicopters
that do amazing things.
FITZ: Build things, play ping
pong, it's pretty incredible.
So we're looking forward to
showing you guys around to see
what we can't find to share with
you that's happening here
at Google I/O After Hours.
BEN: Let's take a look!
FITZ: Let's take a look!
We're over here now with what
looks like a giant snake.
Can you tell us what
your name is?
CHARLIE BRINSON: Yeah, my name
is Charlie Brinson, and I'm
the initiator of this project.
The project's called Titanoboa,
and it's a massive
recreation of this ancient snake
that used to exist 60
million years ago.
FITZ: And just how big
is this snake?
CHARLIE BRINSON: Right
now, this one is
about 40 feet long.
But it's still in the process of
growing, so we're going to
lengthen it to 50 feet to
represent the original kind of
beast that was roaming
the Earth.
BEN: Now, when you say this
project, who is this group
that you're in charge of here?
CHARLIE BRINSON: So I'm the
initiator of the project, and
we have a team of about
15 or 20 people.
We're all working under the
support of a foundation called
eatART, which is Energy
Awareness Through ART.
And we build huge kinetic
sculptures that have
energy-related themes to them.
BEN: What is the energy-related
theme for this sculpture?
CHARLIE BRINSON: Well, we figure
since the story goes
that Titanoboa went extinct 60
million years ago because the
climate cooled down, right?
So now the climate's warming
back up, so we're resurrecting
this beast to get discussions
going about climate change and
showcase electric vehicle
technology.
FITZ: What kind of
locomotion--
does this actually move
like a snake?
CHARLIE BRINSON: Yeah.
So you can see down the spine
there's all these hydraulic
cylinders, which are muscles
of the snake.
And they contract in such a
way that it enables it to
propel itself.
So it's all controlled by a
series of microcontroller
brains all down the spine
and controlled
wirelessly from the driver.
FITZ: And how fast does it go?
Should we be concerned?
CHARLIE BRINSON: Yeah, sometimes
it gets a little bit
of a temper going, and it
can lash out its tail.
But you could probably outrun it
pretty easily, at least at
this stage.
We're planning on modifying it
and upgrading it so that it
can really cruise.
BEN: Are any of the attendees
here going to get a chance to
drive this thing, or
is it experts only?
CHARLIE BRINSON: There's a
pretty big learning curve.
Because it can flick its tail
out and stuff, you've got to
go through a rigorous training
program before you can
actually get behind the--
BEN: Excellent.
FITZ: So other people out there
who are interested in
building really awesome stuff
like this, what's
your advice for them?
CHARLIE BRINSON: Just do it.
Like I had this idea, and we
had no idea whether it was
going to be possible.
But we just kind
of persevered.
And at times it looked really
like, what are we doing?
But once you get to the end and
you've got your product
that looks really awesome,
it's just the
best feeling ever.
BEN: Where can people see this
if they want to see it in
person outside of the show?
Is it going to be in a
museum or exhibit?
CHARLIE BRINSON: We take it to
various exhibits around--
like maybe five or six different
major exhibits
throughout the year.
So you could look it up online
at titanoboa.ca, and then
we'll have posts where
our next show is.
BEN: Titanoboa.ca.
FITZ: Awesome.
BEN: If you want to learn
more about that.
FITZ: All right, so that's
Titanoboa, and we're going to
move on and see what else
we can find around
here to show you guys.
Thanks a lot.
Appreciate it.
BEN: Thank you.
CHARLIE BRINSON: No worries.
BEN: Love your attire,
by the way.
FITZ: Yeah, that's a nice coat
you got there, I have to say.
It looks very distinguished.
BEN: Styling.
FITZ: Excellent.
All right, let's roll.
OK, we're over here with
something incredible.
BEN: I think we're not
in Kansas anymore.
FITZ: So what's your name?
CHRISTIAN RISTOW: Christian
Ristow.
FITZ: And Christian, tell us a
little bit about what we're
standing in front of, and
are we in danger?
CHRISTIAN RISTOW: You are
not actually in danger.
It might be fun to think you
are, but I have other pieces
that would endanger you
more than this one is.
This piece is called
Face Forward.
And it's a 12-foot tall
animatronic human face made
from aluminum and
stainless steel.
It's radio-controlled.
There are 12 points of control
on the face that correspond to
different elements of human
facial expression.
And each of those control points
is controlled from a
control station.
And they're spaced and arranged
in such a way that
one person can really only
operate one at a time.
So the idea is that it takes
12 people to bring
the piece to life.
BEN: Can you tell us what
inspired you to build this?
CHRISTIAN RISTOW: Basically,
I started getting, at some
point, very interested in
the idea of human facial
expression and the musculature
associated with it because
it's fascinating.
We have this amazingly
sensitive, expressive
musculature in our face, which
is devoted to one thing and
one thing only, and that's
communication with other people.
And it functions in ways that
are more subtle and intricate
than we realize.
And we can even occasionally
express things to other people
that we don't really mean to.
And so it's just fascinating,
and I really wanted to build a
piece that captured
that somehow.
And then, almost as an
afterthought, I came up with
this idea of spreading out the
controls and making it
something that would require
12 people to
really bring to life.
And there's an element of an
experiment in cooperation
built into the piece.
There's a degree to which
I have always hoped that
spontaneous cooperation would
emerge among groups of people.
And certain people would perhaps
take on the role of
leader, like OK, everybody,
let's do anger!
And so I have really wanted to
watch the groups of people
controlling the face and wait
and see if something like that
would happen.
It has happened.
It has happened much less
frequently than
I thought it might.
BEN: It's fantastic.
The whole idea of emergent
collaboration is something
that's very near and dear
to our heart, in fact.
It's fascinating stuff.
FITZ: So where can
we go see this?
Is this on permanent display
somewhere, do you travel
around with it?
CHRISTIAN RISTOW: I do travel
around with it.
It's not on permanent display.
It usually goes back home to
my ranch in northern New
Mexico between shows.
It will be, however, at an event
called Artscape which is
a large-scale outdoor public art
festival in Baltimore in
late July, July 20, 21, 22.
FITZ: Great.
CHRISTIAN RISTOW: It will
probably be the Voodoo Fest,
which is a music
festival in New
Orleans right on Halloween.
And it might show up at
Maker Faire, New York.
I'm not sure yet.
BEN: Fantastic.
FITZ: Well, listen, thanks
a lot for taking the
time to show it.
I just hope you a great
time tonight.
CHRISTIAN RISTOW: I thank you.
BEN: I think Googlers are going
to have a great time
with this tonight.
CHRISTIAN RISTOW: Thank you.
FITZ: Let's move on
to the next guy.
BEN: Thank you.
FITZ: All right, thanks.
BEN: Holy smokes, where
are we now?
FITZ: We are here inside
the giant cage
with some flying robots.
Hi, so what's your name?
PROF.
RAFFAELLO D'ANDREA: It's
Raffaello D'Andrea.
FITZ: And where are
you from, and what
exactly is going on here?
PROF.
RAFFAELLO D'ANDREA: I'm a
professor at the Swiss Federal
Institute of Technology.
And what you're seeing here
is a demonstration of
multi-vehicle control.
These flying vehicles are
collaborating to throw a ball
up in the air and then
collaborating to
move and catch it.
FITZ: They're really good.
PROF.
RAFFAELLO D'ANDREA: Yeah,
they're quite good at it.
There's no way that you could
have human beings control
these vehicles to do this.
They're fully autonomous.
They're not remote-controlled
by human beings.
And the precision required
to do this is not
achievable with people.
It has to be done autonomously
with sophisticated algorithms.
BEN: Are they actually tracking
the ball as it falls
back down to the ground?
PROF.
RAFFAELLO D'ANDREA: They are.
The vehicles themselves
are not.
Because we're indoors here, we
have an indoor GPS system,
which is the equivalent
of GPS outside.
And that is what we're using
to track the vehicles.
The ball is being tracked as
it flies, and then the
vehicles figure out exactly
where they need to be to
intercept it.
BEN: That is amazing,
absolutely amazing.
FITZ: And so how big
is your team?
PROF.
RAFFAELLO D'ANDREA: So we have
a rather large team here.
We have about six people here.
We have another 10
folks back home.
We do research on autonomous
systems,
not just flying vehicles.
So it's a team of
about 15 people.
FITZ: And now for the
real question.
How many of these things
have you destroyed in
learning all this?
PROF.
RAFFAELLO D'ANDREA: Right.
So these things are actually
quite robust.
A lot of times, we fly them,
they bounce on the ground, and
they get back up.
But we've probably gone through
10, 20 vehicles.
BEN: Our people who are watching
this at home, they
are developers.
Are they able to play with
autonomous systems like this?
Are there kits they
can buy or things?
PROF.
RAFFAELLO D'ANDREA:
Yeah, there are.
So, I mean, to do this level
of autonomy is beyond--
this is cutting-edge research
that we're doing.
However, you can buy kits
for flying vehicles.
They're rather inexpensive
now.
And if you're willing to do
things with a remote control,
human-piloted, right now it's
very difficult to have fully
autonomous systems, but give it
another two or three years.
BEN: I was thinking about the
things like XB, point-to-point
communication of small
robot insects.
I've seen things like that and
wondering if that's something
people can play with
at home, if it's a
similar sort of problem.
PROF.
RAFFAELLO D'ANDREA: The big
difference with the flying
vehicles, of course, is
that they're unstable.
And if something goes wrong,
they will crash.
So yes, that's great advice
for any hobbyist.
First, start with vehicles on
the ground, so if something
goes wrong, they just
kind of stay put.
Or at worst, they drive
away from you.
But, I mean, five years ago,
we wouldn't even have been
able to come close to what
we're doing now.
So every year more capabilities
are coming around
the corner.
FITZ: I see you've got blocks
over here on a platform.
So these are the robots.
We've seen awesome videos on the
web, and they're building
things, is that right?
PROF.
RAFFAELLO D'ANDREA:
That's correct.
So what you saw right now is
just one of about 10 demos
that we're going to demonstrate
tonight.
One of the other demos is we're
going to build a tower
with our flying vehicles.
And we're going to play
cooperative ping pong.
We're going to balance sticks.
We're going to learn how
to do triple flips.
We're going to do some slalom.
What else are we going to do?
We're going to do a
choreographed dance to music.
BEN: Yeah, this is incredible.
PROF.
RAFFAELLO D'ANDREA: There's
going to be a
bunch of fun stuff.
BEN: Really, really fun.
FITZ: This is officially
amazing.
We're going to have to move on
to catch up with some other
robots, but thank you for your
time and have a great night.
BEN: See you.
Thank you very much.
Hey, hello again.
Here we are at another
station.
And what is your name?
GIL WEINBERG: My name
is Gil Weinberg.
BEN: And what are you doing
here for us today?
GIL WEINBERG: We developed a
robotic docking station.
We believe that every part of
your house should become
robotic, and we'd want to try
with a docking station.
So we think that a docking
station that's not only
playing your music but actually
enjoying the music as
much as you do would be
a nice way to start.
BEN: So you've designed
a docking
station that enjoys music?
GIL WEINBERG: We tried to have
it dance and enjoy music and
be your companion.
So it can recommend
music to you.
It can tell you what he thinks
about your taste.
If he doesn't like what you
like, he can have a gesture or
a sound, something that you can
interact with, learn about
music, and enjoy music more
when you listen to it.
BEN: Sounds like what Fitz does
with me all the time.
FITZ: Can we take
a look at it?
Can we get a little demo here?
GIL WEINBERG: So one quick demo
would be me trying to
clap a song.
And it goes through the cloud
trying to find a song that is
matching my clapping.
And let's see if it works.
FITZ: We've got a lot
of noise here.
Let's see what it does.
BEN: All right, you're going
to clap a tempo?
GIL WEINBERG: Yeah.
Oh, we don't have sound.
This is something we've found.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN: It's boogying.
GIL WEINBERG: Try it again.
FITZ: Try it again?
All right.
BEN: One more time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GIL WEINBERG: Well, that was
the rhythm that I wanted at
the same beat.
BEN: Yeah.
GIL WEINBERG: It detects
the beat.
It detects the tempo, and brings
you songs that fits.
FITZ: So it detects the beat
and the tempo, and it finds
something in the cloud,
and it starts playing?
GIL WEINBERG: Right.
And another thing that I wanted
to show you is we have
all the robots dancing
together.
FITZ: So they synchronize?
GIL WEINBERG: Yeah.
What's nice about it is that all
the brain of the robot is
on the phone.
So it has all the computation,
the networking.
It has all your input,
the vision.
When you move, the robot always
know where you are, so
you're always in the center
of the stereo field.
FITZ: So it's a peripheral,
basically, for your phone?
GIL WEINBERG: Basically.
BEN: And it's tracking you, you
said, as you walk around?
GIL WEINBERG: Because you have a
phone here, we have a lot of
capabilities that make this
robot pretty cheap.
This can be a $100 robot.
BEN: Wow.
GIL WEINBERG: And all
the brain is pretty
much in your pocket.
When you take the brain from the
pocket and put it in the
dock, suddenly the robot
becomes smart.
It can communicate.
It can network with
each other.
It can look at you, and you're
always in the center of the
stereo field.
BEN: Can these coordinate
for us?
GIL WEINBERG: Yeah,
these coordinate.
Mason, you want to try to
make them coordinate?
FITZ: Yeah, let's
give it a try.
BEN: Yeah, one more time.
Let's watch.
FITZ: So how do we do that?
GIL WEINBERG: They
just started.
FITZ: There they go, OK.
I see there's two of
them going, and
there's the middle one.
All right, that's pretty cool.
So if I really wanted to buy one
of these, can I go buy one
today at the store?
GIL WEINBERG: We hope to
make them affordable.
As I mentioned, this can
be a $100 robot.
We want to have it ready
by January of 2013.
What's nice about it is that
it can use sounds that it
makes by itself or sounds
from your music library.
In this case, as you hear
right now, it actually
synthesizes in real time
based on the gestures.
The gestures actually
generate a sound.
FITZ: OK.
BEN: Wonderful.
And this is programmable,
I assume?
GIL WEINBERG: It's
programmable.
We want to have an application
for kids, for
education, for gaming.
There will be an API.
And I think just now, they're
about to play together, so
maybe we can finish with
a little song that
they all play together.
BEN: Let's watch the
very end here.
Thank you so much.
FITZ: All right, thanks.
For all you engineers out there
who don't want to dance
like me, you've got something
to dance for you.
Let's move on and see if there's
anything else to see.
Thanks a lot.
GIL WEINBERG: You'll be fine.
FITZ: Have a good night.